my name is Tim Wong I work in Nvidia in
the automotive group I handle techno
marketing so you may know Nvidia as a
gaming company but we are so much more
than that we are heavily in debt
official intelligence virtual reality
and self-driving cars which is why we're
here today to talk about you and I both
drive with just our eyes and for better
or worse humans are terrible at paying
attention whereas the car is always
being attention it can look all the way
around it and that's where deep learning
comes in is I can basically train a car
to understand whether it's lanes whether
it's pedestrians whether it's a moose or
a deer I can train all these different
things and the more objects I can
classify I actually don't increase the
reaction time of the network you can
understand all these things in the world
around you you can make your car
essentially intelligent and basically
keep the occupant safe and have the car
drive autonomously what the Udacity nano
degree program does is it raises that
capability of the engineers coming in to
Nvidia that now I know they know about
deep learning they know about
traditional CV and they can hit the
ground running very quickly this whole
autonomous vehicle injury is a very
exciting industry there's just so much
to be discovered so much to understand
and to us deep learning and GPUs
essentially how you're going to do it my
name is Jennifer Griffin and I am the
director of university recruiting at
Nvidia so we're really looking for
several things in the students that we
choose to interview I would say the most
important thing that we're looking for
is passion you have to be passionate
about the industry you have to be
passionate about the more macro industry
of artificial intelligence and machine
learning and self-driving cars and what
that can bring to the world showing
passion showing that you really
understand the technology where it could
go that all makes you a great candidate
once you're here those interviews are
usually pretty technical and so what
that means that you'll actually be
standing at a whiteboard with a marker
coding or doing something that is
technical not necessarily if you can get
from A to B but how you get there even
if you don't get the answer right we
want to see your thought process for how
to get there and that's
more valuable to us than your final
answer it seems like every week there
are a couple of autonomous vehicle
announcements so being up on current
events is is a very big thing showing
that you know the industry and you know
the current trends is always very
important always helpful in your new
view our internship programs are
real-world projects they are 12 weeks
long and they're determined ahead of
time what the projects going to be in
this performance management and guidance
built in along the way I think the most
important thing to know about the
internship program is that it is our
most strategic pipeline to new College
grant hiring so anyone who comes in as
an intern is automatically considered
for a full-time role once they graduate
you need to bring your authentic self to
work here and that's the only way it
works here this is work life integration
that we're doing here so I bring
everything about me to work every day
including the fact that I'm a woman and
I feel appreciated for that here and I
feel like I'm definitely supported here
in terms of all the facets of my life we
are so incredibly open to diverse skill
sets and diverse paths to get to a skill
set we're hiring people we're not hiring
pedigrees we absolutely focus on what
the individual will bring to the table
into the team and what we can do for the
individual as well there's tons of
camaraderie there's lots of fun there's
a ton of hard work I feel like I am
holding on to the tail end of a rocket
ship and I didn't even know what a
rocket ship it was gonna be when I
joined I look every day at the news
coming out of Nvidia and and my mind is
absolutely blown Atanas equals improved
quality of life and that's to me what
makes it exciting
and that I'm a part of this I'm a part
of making something that's useful for
society solves a fundamental problem and
improves people's lives
Oh
[Music]